welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host his and on this week's episode I
was joined by Harry porch who is the
solo founder of hm Staffing after 18
months working for another business
Harry decided to go out on his own
some may say that's naive I think he'll
be the first to say that he owned that
and Was Naive at the beginning of his
journey but they've now been in business
for four years and he really shared with
us in this episode the highs and lows of
going out on your own with let's be
honest not a ton of experience behind
you he shared with us the challenges
that he faced being a 20 year old solo
founder of a recruitment business and
the tons of challenges that have come
along the way from hiring from growing
but also plenty of the things that
they've learned how they've done things
differently they've really invested a
lot into marketing and really going
against the norm of what a typical
recruitment business should be doing I'm
really excited to see this business as a
far evolve but look that's enough from
me enjoy this week's episode
Harry welcome to the podcast thanks for
having me mate thanks for making the
trip that was all right it wasn't too
bad no cancellations nothing just came
straight through from Reading yep which
um you've you've built a local reading
recruitment business which I find really
interesting which I know we're gonna go
into but thanks for making a trip uh I
guess I always like to start with the
million pound question and I'm sure it's
something that you thought more and more
about since having your own recruitment
business
but I guess just to help people
listening to sort of understand where
you're at on your journey feel free to I
guess fill in any of the blanks yeah of
course but what I just found super
interesting about your journey is you're
someone that yeah worked in recruitment
for less than two years for 18 months
then started your own recruitment
business and you've been on that Journey
now for the last four years so today
there's nine of you in the business
um have an office in Reading satellite
office in Manchester who just recently
launched your first Academy where you've
hired a couple of people at the same
time and you're taking them through a
whole journey and I think in this in
this conversation I'm really Keen to
talk about the highs and lows the
challenges and everything that you've
learned along the way around the last
four years the fun stuff isn't it um but
if we could start with yeah like when I
say to you what what are the
characteristics and traits that you
believe May copper a highly successful
recruiter in today's market what comes
up for you on that there's so many
different things there's one that always
stands out for me it's just having guts
so not even just we've got to like
picking up the phone but having those
like really difficult questions with
candidates clients
um picking up the phones one thing
especially when you first start right I
think everyone's a bit scared to to pick
the phone up especially when it's
clients but the other thing as well is
not to take things personally I used to
start life someone said no I thought
they were saying like no to me
personally and I get so caught up on it
and I'd be thinking in the back of my
head for so long and then I had to
separate that okay it's not actually
saying no to me personally it's you know
it's the same no to recruitment agencies
that say no to the company because it'll
proper bug me it would bug me for so
long if I could say a client didn't want
to work with us and everything like that
but there are two things that I think
you you have to sort of get from the
start having the guts is massive as well
right on the taking the personal thing
I'm sure you've had to help people with
that now yeah
let me just ask you something on that
because I think a lot of people
listening I I definitely struggled with
that early on yeah because you're
dealing with people as well as your
product it's if there's a lot more
emotions
to like I know you just said there you
had to separate them but like what if
I'm listening right now and I am taking
things personally and I find myself
thinking about that client rejecting me
three weeks after it's happened yeah
what was your advice for those people to
get better at yeah moving away from that
or not taking the emotions out of it
it's just difficult one isn't it because
it it one day it just happens and it's
one of those things I just have to
remind my team all the time and they're
not saying no to let's say if it was
Jack they're not saying no to Jack
Bennett saying no to Jack button from hm
staff and it's two different people
right now when you come into work you're
someone when you leave work you're that
person that person's not gonna say if
you're face to face right and you asked
my question the likelihood of the
response I gave you on the phone in
person is not going to be the same
that's maybe quite rude on the phone for
example can't they um which are
interesting interesting people but um
yeah it's hard to actually do it I think
it's just a constant reminder I had to
keep telling myself keep telling myself
keep telling myself that it's not
personal it's not personal it's not
personal until it actually stuck I don't
think it's something you can teach
yourself how to film okay interesting so
having guts I think I'm that's
interesting that you've said that
because I feel like looking at your
journey you've probably had to have
quite a bit of that yeah and naivety but
yeah so so do you worked in recruitment
for 18 months yeah and then you decided
to start your own recruitment business
at 20 years old and then you've
obviously been on that Journey now for
the last four years so so when when did
you start the business without it being
2018 yes in December time December 2018.
yeah back end of December so I was
completely done with the last agency I
was at yeah and I just thought you know
what why not I didn't want to go work
with someone else I was saying to you
I'd been on a night out of a mate in
Bristol I woke up and I had like four
calls from internal Recruiters in
Reading I was like how'd you get my
number never found out it wasn't
anywhere and then yeah I think it was
that moment I was like I don't want to
work for another company like this I
don't like how a lot of things are done
with recruitment agency so I was like
all right I'm just gonna
do it myself which was um I was naive at
the time but it's I think that's paid
off so let's just break this down into
first year yeah it's a whole of 2019
basically was your first year yeah March
like what what was the mindset was it
like and what were your circumstances
were you living at home in the parents
yeah so living at home yeah I didn't
have any bills in that since I owned my
car and everything like that
um so I didn't have any like major
outgoings I just thought what have I got
to lose with this I knew that there'd be
certain clients that want to work with
me um and I was thinking I was right
let's say if I can bring two clients on
and do 40K in the first year that's more
than the salary that I would be getting
elsewhere plus probably enough to cover
my costs and then we got yeah we had a
few clients that came on board straight
away that I was like right what are we
going to get this first year from you
guys and we worked out okay we're
actually gonna do quite well so then
hired people in got an office it was my
dining room table from December to March
then I went to this office that's
probably not the size of my me and you
sat away it was horrible I really lived
it it had no windows nothing like that
it was um there was a proper box but
yeah it was it was it was interesting so
dining room table yeah the first couple
of months just I guess like like I said
what what's the worst that can happen
yep try and do some deals
did some of those how long does it take
to do your first build remember or six
weeks six weeks yeah and that's from
actually setting up actually was it yeah
six weeks till the invoice got sent out
right so I was like right what am I
gonna do like it came on in December and
I was like it's over Christmas or
anything like that and they were like I
would look at it in January and I'm like
okay that's fine I was like Excel
spreadsheet was up I was thinking which
job board's gonna be the cheapest for me
to find someone so I had a trial with I
think you'll have ncv library and that's
how I got the first one in so I didn't
really have to pay for anything I was
just using like my own laptop my
personal phone and everything like that
um so yeah it's six weeks until the
invoice went out and they started and
then that was when it really hit I was
like right okay we could actually build
something here and they gave us another
three jobs really so straight away I was
like right okay hang on we've got some
momentum here and then it just carried
on from there and then you made your
first high in April yes so April hide on
my best mates you're your best mates
yeah was it was just you two for the
rest of the year it was us two for three
months and behind two people yeah which
yeah so some of the highest didn't work
out um I think I was at the start
looking at all right would I get along
with you I said I wasn't looking at
anything else like could I grab a beer
with you could I chill with you and
everything like that which is definitely
not the right mindset for hiring and I
should have known that because we hired
for everyone else right but when it's
actually hiring for yourself it's a bit
different
um so yeah we made made some wrong highs
and everything like that yeah you'd be
surprised how common that is uh everyone
does it but so just just so we
understand that so the end of the first
year did it end up still still being
just shooting I made it despite no
I think there's four of us by the end of
the first show yeah okay let's just talk
about this first year then for a sec
because
I think a lot of people like you just
said they you went out in Bristol or
let's say you went out down the pub in
in reading and
a bunch go into
um meet a bunch of recruiters yeah I
think a typical sentence you'll hear is
our one that I'm gonna do it on my own
or uh I know I could do this on my own
these stuff yeah but a lot of people
don't have the guts to tell them okay as
well I was in turkey and I was just I
was with my mate at the time and uh
there was two recruiters and they're
both talking about it I just jumped in
the conversation so I'll get involved in
this chat but yeah no you hear it
everywhere yeah so like what in that
first year I know you said there's
plenty of obviously you being naive
what have you got to lose but what was I
guess my channel in that first year that
you least expected
I think it was like personal battles I
think there's a bit of an ego that
probably came with it because it started
doing well so I had the clients in our
three four that I was the man to a
certain degree but age came into it a
lot right a lot of we go meet clients
and stuff for that and they'd look at me
and they'd be like you're a kid oh yeah
that's so much and I was there like yeah
but okay let's say if you go and dealt
with a consultant at one of the bigger
agencies the likeliers they're gonna be
some rage to me right so we had that
quite a lot and that was something that
was used against us and now we switched
it around now we use it in a more
positive way
um but that was something we had quite a
lot and it was a big challenge to sort
of overcome that managing people that
are older than me that was a real big
challenge
um just more of a learning curve for me
I probably did it wrong as well but
looking back there's probably certain
things I should have done a bit better
but I said they were the big big
challenges in that first year so quite a
lot of anchored to your age then yeah oh
it always is always was at a start at
the start but I know I'd have shook my
shoulder about it as well do you think
you brought that on yourself like
because did you did you almost
potentially go into situations thinking
oh like are they going to think like I'm
just too young yeah 100 I used to I used
to see it as a negative so then I then I
felt like everyone else saw it as a
negative so then as soon as I over
became that and I was like you know I
can actually make it's like a really
positive thing and that'll work so well
for us when we talk about it
um but yeah back then it was because I
saw a negative way it means that
everyone else did
so interesting because I think people
would assume yeah like but at the same
like when you say you've now turn it
into positive yeah
what so the the negative perception of
Harry's too young to be doing the to be
running his own recruitment business or
like them potentially thinking that I'm
too young was what you haven't got
enough experience like yeah that's what
you that was like the story you were
telling yourself yeah but then what what
was the story you started telling
yourself as to make it more of a
positive well at that point age I got
older first of all we had more years
years of experience so it didn't look
like something that was in the first
year we could say okay well you set up
when he was 20 you know nearly four
years old now we've gone and done this
and I think the little achievements
along the way kind of helped me frame it
in a different position when Awards all
be spoken for LinkedIn and then when we
throw those things into the story then
it turns out to be really impressive not
just some kid that's trying to do it
what I take from that is you've over
time obviously you've gathered more and
more evidence as to why you yeah you can
wow yeah yeah
advice like what would you say to Harry
then if you're starting again like
because clearly you've gone on to
continue to build credibility yeah back
yourself more confidence but like what
would you go back and say to Harry who
had that real chip in the shoulder and
viewed his ages and negative thing going
into that first year I'd say one thing
you don't take things too personally I I
have to say to everyone now but um just
to shut up a bit as well but I just
would talk way too much but like to tell
everyone what we were always up to and
everything like that which probably
didn't help in fact everyone's like oh
he's just he's just a kid he just like
talks way too much and everything like
that we spoke about like ego sort of
things and I called before I said I
think that does come in I think when you
put yourself in a position where people
are looking up to you in a business
world where they're looking to like
management or jobs and stuff like that
then that does inflate massively um so
I'd say just watch that and don't take
things too personal so you almost you
think maybe you overcompensated but yeah
yeah just speaking a lot and yeah oh 100
so I just learned just to be quiet
sometimes
um right evening client meetings you've
just I'm not rambling on and someone's
like oh tell us about yourself you know
speaking for like five minutes thinking
what am I doing just just calm down a
bit
um but yeah there's a lot of pressure on
them I've got a lot of pressure on
myself to make sure that it succeeded
because of other people thinking that oh
it wouldn't and stuff like that and then
so then at that point as well like what
about like mentally outside of work like
did you have any challenges there like
was your family super supportive or what
were they thinking about what is Harry
no they they were supportive they were
uh we were in the office from like six
to eleven I probably put like 30
kilograms yeah oh yeah it's horrible
well we were just saying I'd deliver it
every day
um it was such an unhealthy life I would
go to the gym for ages just because
something I don't know I need to be at
work and he's working constantly
um I hardly saw my mates and everything
like that um so those relationships and
such obviously took a bit of a bit of a
turn everything like that um there was
like oh he thinks he's too busy for us
it's something I'm just really trying to
focus on this and build something for my
future
um so a lot outside of work definitely
that first year took a bit of a hit but
so did you almost like did you have it
and I guess at that age as well I mean
I'm 29 so when I was 20
I def I definitely didn't have the only
thing that I found myself doing was I
was selling products on Amazon yeah it
wasn't like I was hiring people and
stuff like that but that can be
difficult when you're that Asian you
have no one else that is on like a did
you have no one else that was on
obviously you had your best mate but
there's no one else in like a similar
path
not that I could see not not in that
space anyway there's a few people that I
knew that had my groups changed you know
throughout the years and now there's a
lot more business owners in that
friendship group and everything like
that but at the start no one else that I
knew was doing anything similar so
exactly yeah yeah massive
and they almost felt like again you were
too busy for them which is yeah I think
again it's not it's an awkward
conversation so when you do then go out
and I was like oh look oh look who it is
and stuff like that like really we're
doing this
um but yeah it was tricky at the time
because I just wanted to be like my
mates there were so many times I was
thinking like should I just sat this off
and you know go work with someone else
and I can still actually enjoy my
childhood I could guess you could call
it that still because that's what
everyone says all their best shoes like
you're 18 19 20 21 that kind of stuff
like you're out with your mates you're
making memories and stuff like that and
I was just sat in a box office for most
of the time but just putting on loads of
weight yeah oh the life looking back at
it there's some photos we did um
recently at company presentation and
there's um a few photos of me then
everyone's like who's that and I'm like
really that's me I'll show you something
about it they're gold they are gold yeah
yeah so you mentioned that why didn't
you quit
I do you know at that point I was
probably thinking I know I need to do
this myself to prove other people wrong
a little bit so like I think in that
first year I was thinking I could make
such a better salary I can make much
better money and I think I know this is
definitely a long a long game
um and then as the years went on we
built the right people around us and
stuff like that and I'm so happy that I
did stick out if my brother was quite
big in that actually if I like said
about anything like that he'd just give
me like a funny look and go what do you
want about your brother how how would
your brother 25 now so he was he's 18
months older than me so he'd always like
be on my shoulder what are you talking
about he's like shut up get on with it
and stuff like that it's quite brutal
he's still like that now if I'm worn
about anything he just tells me to shut
up really but um but yeah no so he um he
was quite big in that as well I don't
want to let down the people that
supported me as well and showed a lot of
love for the early stages
um so that did keep me going a lot of
time in the dark days and stuff for that
you sat in your car thinking about what
am I doing is it worth it and everything
like that they um those people really
kept it so and then the final thing then
a lot of people underestimate like I
know you said at the beginning like oh
you literally have your laptop next
Excel spreadsheet you literally had the
trial and CV larger and you found
someone that you placed but like
operationally the the business stuff
that oftentimes I speak to people when
they underestimate how much time that
takes or
like you know what's involved in terms
of like the finance side of things and
like this the operations
did was any of that difficult like in
the first year because obviously before
all you had to worry about was you just
looking at your pay packet and if you've
got paid the correct Commission on like
I didn't have to worry about all the
other stuff right yeah was that a
challenge in that first year adjusting
to that it was I don't feel like I did
it very well I was quite lucky with one
of them because um well that's an
accountant your dad's an accountant yeah
so I was quite lucky with with that one
because he managed to help me out with
sort of finances in like looking at them
and looking after them and
um so he supported me with that part of
it but the rest of it I was shocking
like like processes and stuff like that
I just wouldn't document anything like
looking back now I'm thinking Hi-Fi I've
actually done that right at the start
then I wouldn't have to be doing it now
and so many different things with it but
yeah that was um it was a nightmare this
was the main thing that Pro when you
said process is like what would you mean
even stuff like now I wish I documented
it would be stuff like how you find a
candidate and stuff like that and
actually just document it especially at
the start when I had a lot more time he
said now trying to document it out the
last over the last three years been
doing it and stuff
um or having a system from the start
obviously I'd get a system where he's
been Cherry now but I'd get that early
as I could as soon as I had the budget
for I didn't really do it for six months
she's an Excel spreadsheet yeah it just
downloads my laptop and I was like would
remember it in a notebook and stuff like
that and but yeah it was it wasn't too
challenging but I'd get stuff like that
straight away you know you start
documenting everything from the start
because at that point is you're never
gonna have to go back and redo it and
everything like that or be worried about
what could happen if you know have a CV
in your laptop and gdpr and all of that
no no I just respect that because I
think what what you just lent into was
just taking action and then like working
out as you go I think a lot of people
think they have to have all that sorted
out before they can even take steps
forward yeah yeah I don't have my phone
as well just like it literally just my
phone laptop or Excel spreadsheet that's
Excel spreadsheet I've already used it
like five times right I did not keep
track on it I had it there and it was It
was supposed to be used and I used it a
bit and it would be more like okay so I
had an interview I'd have it all in
there but I'd have my calendar would
just be full of just like everything
interviews calls with everyone I'll be
religious with that
um I've still got my notebook for my
first year yeah yeah my handwriting is
terrible I'm getting slated on LinkedIn
at the moment because everyone keeps
posting our non-negotiables and I was
like who's written that I never thought
of that and it's like oh that me yeah
it's terrible so what what I really find
interesting about your business is like
how you really focused on it being
localized yep
because I'll be honest with you most
people that I sit down and speak with
would say like in today's market you
it's really important that you have a
nation of focus yeah and I know you have
a few different sectors that you um
focus on but I don't know from what you
shared them and feel free to add context
whatever it also felt quite General but
like what you focused on is it is it
being really local in terms of mainly
around the reading area yep
so talk to me a bit about how the sort
of approach to your business has um
evolved like because obviously if I went
on your website there's a number of
different sectors on there like how how
have you approached that and and I don't
know how is the sort of focusing on your
local area played out so that's a lot of
our stuff sparksure like 90 of it the
other 10 you know we do go into London
and stuff like that um it's normally
when we get brought into London it's
never normally we like aim and Target
companies in London
um but it slowly has sort of progressed
we've got a few in Manchester and
everything like that where the satellite
offices and and stuff like that but that
it was kind of what I was used to doing
the office support sales marketing HR
those key areas there but also a lot of
the clients that we get in with that
might have a marketing manager role for
us the likelihood of them having a sales
team and an admin person and an admin
department or HR and everything like
that is so high that normally we'd get
in with a company and the repeat
business in there is so much that it's a
lot easier for us to do that than
focusing on 100 different Market
managerials and only work in that so
that's how we split in between desks so
it'll get to a point soon where we've
got two people per desk so I'll just
play Sorry what'd you mean so it depends
on the person and who I think they'll be
best speaking to because the candidates
for all those different rounds are so
different
um so it's normal description sales
marketing HR
um office support and then in a sales
marketing but it's a bit bigger because
then they split in between them with
sales so you have people that just do
sales and marketing HR yeah but then
it's not like sector specific it's just
more like local box in the boxer area
exactly that um because a lot of the
people that are good for let's say Okay
telecoms admin role are also good for a
retail management role or a sales admin
role a Manufacturing Company a lot of
them it's a similar background and
they're all looking for the same thing
so us being really targeted to let's say
only cyber a couple of the people we're
placing now would also be good for a
different industry so for us it didn't
seem much Point having that really
specific don't get me wrong there's a
few of the guys that they really focus
on certain industries and stuff like
that just because they've got a good can
that it's in those areas but it's such a
mix which makes people a lot of the time
they actually come into work enjoy it a
bit more as well because they're not
constantly just speaking to the same
people non-stop same Industries they do
get to work with mixer clients which I
know they enjoy because I think one of
the obviously one of the things that I
think you guys have done really well and
I think if people almost know your foot
is your brand yeah and I think when
we're speaking about this I think what
I've found really interesting was how
much of a positive impact it's had on
Distributing a local business hiring
local people recruiting for the local
area are you just telling me how like
yeah you could like if you think about
it the the people that you hire that
might be a bit younger than you or
whatever like they will know people that
are working in the local area and it
just all just keeps growing and I just
found that really interesting but I
guess talk to us a bit about like why
have you really tried to go against a
status quo I think that's how people
would I don't know I was looking at your
old post today and like I'd I feel like
that's almost a perception that you've
built like you're going against like the
grain or like how to typically do that
where where's that come from
I'm not sure where it's come from well I
know where the videos have come from
that kind of content has because
um a friend of mine he owns a company
that that's what they specialize in for
massive massive Brands and I thought
could we make this about recruitment
work so we started doing that and then
I've given the team just like
flexibility to their LinkedIn you know
build your own personal brand make
people laugh on it and people remember
you
um so I went to meeting with the council
doing some advisory work for them and
there was someone there to recognize us
from my LinkedIn content straight away
and they were just laughing about it and
stuff like that and they were like oh
well if you want to have a chat about
recruitment as well so all these good
conversations have been coming from it
um but yeah we get the flexibility for
them to kind of do
what they want within reason and there's
a few posts I get sent like oh what do
you think about this a bit risky and I'm
not like
let's just let's just leave that one out
um so yeah some of them and I'm thinking
wait why did you think that that would
be a good idea but some of them do
really well like the ferret one Jack did
the other week I think they've done like
two million views now and I know for a
fact that he wouldn't get that exposure
doing like a recruitment post something
just about recruitment oh yeah
recruitment I'm finding this in a trend
and that and that and um I think right
or which is a way to get out there you
know we haven't got this big marketing
budget that a lot of companies have so
let's have some fun with it and it's
done it's done really well for us to be
fair and it's made that brand really
strong that when we internally recruit
we've never struggled with Elegance we
get loads coming
so it's impact internally yeah what
about obviously that was one of my other
questions like how because I think I saw
I think I wrote it down here like one of
the posts that you did was around I
don't know if it was you or one of your
colleagues but like I think it said I
still find it funny how many people say
your post videos are cringe or
embarrassing but then like but then you
actually get a business Yeah Yeah from
it so you just mentioned there I got
wound up that day yeah but like
obviously you just mentioned it it helps
you hire internally yeah that's a huge
challenge for 99 of recruitment
businesses so it has helped on there but
how was it how is it manifested
investing in your brand and doing things
a bit differently on like client
acquisition or other parts of the
business like how's that that it
normally helps normally helps um I had
someone the other week
um they're a client and we don't want to
work with them anymore and they said no
this ridiculously long abusive email and
it did say in it like oh obviously you
don't care about your business because
the [ __ ] you post on YouTube oh wow and
I was like okay fair enough that's your
opinion on it but that was also that
that mdl that company is probably in the
60s not understand what we're trying to
do and who we're trying to get in with
and everything like that
um but most of them love it most of them
absolutely love it we've had some
massive massive companies come on from
it um the ones that don't like it are
really traditional businesses that are
still stuck in the past in my opinion
all recruitment is a lot don't like it
um I I've had quite a lot about it when
I go out people say oh my director hates
your content I'm like okay
it's different that's what it normally
is and they might be seeing people
engaging with it and they wish they
could be getting the engagement on it it
could be anything or I wish we had that
idea
um because a few people said to me I
went to my director and said oh we
should do a post this and he was like no
we can't do that that's ridiculous and
stuff like that
um it could just be a bit like it could
be a bit of jealousy it could be
anything
um but I think where we're trying not to
be stuck in an old way and actually be
forward thinking and thinking well how
can we get out there without spending
you know thousands and thousands that
studio that we record everything is in
our office so it's actually next door
we're in a service office so for us to
film content we literally go in there
for half an hour on lunch do it and then
come back in they send it to us the next
day and it's done so when you say it's
so like just to be clear like how does
how does it actually happen does it like
does he do you or any of your team
literally get messages like hey harry
love your content we've got a number of
roles at the moment like we're local
we'd love to speak to you like what what
does it actually look like yeah so we
had that the other week with one of the
I'm not gonna say that yeah but yeah
yeah well it's probably on the you know
household name I could say off camera
yeah I'll know them straight away and it
happened again uh recently
um there's lovely content um really want
to work with you guys we like what
you're doing I've been finding quite
funny or we like the brand you're trying
to build it's a bit different it's
refreshing which is what we're trying to
be and we've had I think about five or
six I think we've done about
field roles from it for about 25 I'd say
in the last year I'm actually just
posting constantly about stuff
um that's inbound which just means as
well it's just less outline activity
which I think everyone would love that
to happen that less outbound more
inbound um which where we want to get it
to be we want stuff coming in all the
time but yeah we get reached out
LinkedIn about it uh people call the
office say I found this video funny
we've got a role in HR can you guys help
us out with it but normally it then puts
us a position where when we say our fees
people aren't arguing it I know I don't
want to pay that I'll be paying 12.5
instead of 20 or 17.5 for example most
people may say off either go yeah that's
fine so it's helped us put us in a
position of authority you could say and
people don't really argue that part so
we get better fees better clients and
actually just all around better
relationships hey everyone a real quick
one from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
Partners Vin cherry and saucebreaker
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products and
like yeah I think I think what you've
definitely nailed is like the
the comedic element as well obviously
I've really enjoyed that video that you
guys put together on like obviously
reading the the tweets yeah
yeah it is look that's that's a big part
of um why I started this because I I
actually do I guess because I'm in my
little Echo chamber like I'm speaking to
people that want to be the best
recruiter they can be want to deliver
the best service want to change the
protection in the industry
but there's still so many people out
there receiving poor experiences so yeah
like yeah if you haven't seen that video
I'll definitely check it out is is is
hilarious in terms of reading the tweets
and what people say about recruiters
there's one person that they've tweeted
or they've been involved in every single
video we've done because they're so
active about the hate for recruiters and
we're doing a few more and he he's in it
again and then I'm going to reach out to
him and see if he'll do a video of us
um him and George yeah Jeff versus
George is what it's going to be cool but
um yeah I feel like he's gonna say no
he's a big like some CEO in America
um but yeah I'm gonna see if I can get
on the zoom call I think it'd just be
funny anyone that's seen the content
will then will be able to appreciate it
um yeah we're doing a bit more about
what people think about recruiters soon
so how how has like let's just fast
forward a bit then obviously you then
had to go in covert that must have been
a challenge but I guess what I'd just be
interested to go into is like how
obviously you started like I said a bit
naive had a bit of a chip in your
shoulder
20 years old and you obviously wrestled
with that but how have you had to like
evolve as a Harry has had to evolve as a
business owner like what are some of the
things that you really had to
I don't know be like
harsh with yourself on and get better at
and improve on and spend time and like
have you had to like grow up as a
business owner a lot
um which is it's awesome but I've just
been a bit more mature about certain
things as well and I struggle to keep
concentrated on anything so I've got add
dyslexic and everything like that so for
me it's like that's a bit like an
ongoing battle I'll get distracted of
anything and as well it's not letting
myself get distracted with other people
and stuff that I've been the easy one to
distract in the office and I should read
the last one that should that should be
that person or someone could just say
something on there like oh yeah what's
that and then yeah so that that's been
one thing
um the management side of things has
been a bit more having a little sympathy
with people and understanding people
that's obviously it's always a bit of a
bit of a challenge I might just get on
with your work so what's wrong there's a
fan and learning to understand people a
bit better
um but I said it's been part of like an
interesting because I saw that like
you've got you've got like a coach or
someone that you work yes Dave when when
did that start that started just so we
started speaking just before covid um it
was actually the week before
um we've got a few mutuals known for
that and we always knew of each other
everyone thinks he's fake by the way
because his name is Dave Davies so
everyone said hello oh you just give me
a fake name get out of this conversation
I'm like no like that's legit his name
um but yeah we had a few Mutual
connections and stuff like that and we'd
always speak on it then I met him out at
roasted Cuba we were out in Reading
um just before covert happens we've got
speaking in there and then we kept in
touch about lockdown we went to the same
networking events and um it got to the
end of it and I was like yeah I
definitely need your help to a certain
degree with the sales training as well I
think there's only so much sales
training you can do as as a business
leader to get someone else in that's
what they're experience in there an
expert in that industry that area even
is is so vital
um I still get now loads of people like
sales coaches reach out to me I actually
had one go through an ex-girlfriend of
mine to try to get me as a client oh
really yeah really weird it's absolutely
freaked me out like they don't matter
there must be like a referral fee in
here somewhere and stuff like that but I
opened me up a week I'm just like what
are you going on so what did you do with
this guy so Dave we see Dave every
Fortnight for half a day and sometimes
it once a month depends on how busy we
are
um and the whole team all of us even me
will go and have sales training with him
and then I see in weekly every Monday
and we go through sort of what
challenges you know he gives me a bit of
management coaching for example if I say
I'm really stuck on this how would you
and then it gives me like a different
perspective or so it's like bugging me
as well it's a big thing if I say it to
him he's like hey why is it broken it
let me break it down and by the end of
it I think what am I doing why am I
letting that bother me and stuff like
that
um but sometimes when you know that your
decision you've got to make and you're
putting a self-off fix it's such a hard
decision to make and he's a good person
that I can talk through with it and I
come off the call and they're like okay
I know what I need to do I'm gonna say
how much does that help then it's so
much so much
um I don't think we'd be in a position
where we are now if it wasn't for him
um I've had some ideas that he thinks
that he's like oh do you really think
that's a good idea and I'm like yeah I
do and he's like why and I'm like I go
for it
like what am I doing
um but yeah it helps massively I think
that the age thing comes into it I think
he's been in business for like 30 years
I'm not going to say any anymore because
he'll tell me off saying he's old but
um but yeah having that person I can
turn to is like a mentor as well is is
so so important for me and how what
would your advice be for someone
listening to this that like would love
to be engaged with someone like that
they're a solo founder have challenges
like it's in It Happened quite
organically obviously the night out and
you connected but I don't know if you
like known how impactful that's been
yeah if you're to be like right I need
to like be really intentional about
finding someone that can help me with
that how I don't know what would advice
be to people about how to go about
finding someone like Dave it's
got one isn't it because most people say
I'll find someone recruitment an expert
recruitment one but Dave's General so he
doesn't just work recruit he's working
with the cyber security companies and
data companies he's worked with
recruitment companies before obviously
um but I use him because for me he knows
loads of Industries we work within those
different Industries so it made sense
um but don't post on LinkedIn
recommendations and you get every single
person in the world coming to their
uncle brother and son and stuff like
that whenever I see that I'll always
message him saying I'll have a chat with
Dave he's who we use
um but I didn't meet as many of them as
you can and actually see the one you
connect with the most that you get along
with because you're going to want to
spend time with them which is going to
help you in the long run
um the reason we picked Dave is because
of how much of a laugh he is and how I
know how good he is if I didn't have
such a laugh of him I couldn't I
couldn't work from I don't think it then
would have benefited us as much
interesting so what what have been like
if we think over the last like two years
where you've really been obviously
pushing the business forward
like what have been some of the the
different challenges that you've found
yourself maybe speaking to Dave about or
having to work for it I say team members
is is one thing
um if it's something this one has done
something or if I think right
oh do we want to be keeping you or not
performance of certain people like stuff
like that um that's the stuff where it
comes so in handy because say if you've
got someone there we're not performing
well you've got to first of all thinking
why they're not performing well what can
I do just make them
perform a lot better I don't know the
numbers go up and everything like that
so that stuff I speak to him about there
um
or stuff like making decisions there's
some people that you really want to keep
around but you really shouldn't be
keeping around
um I think everyone yeah everyone's got
people like that
um and talking talking through that
that's yeah that's been a big
big half I've got to be careful I say
about something some things like that
but yeah it's um but like it's the
people element like running a business
in the people element making difficult
decisions yeah it's clients as well
actually um it introduces quite a lot of
clients which is always great as well so
if anything he makes the money back but
we spend with him it's great it's a
no-brainer
um but sometimes there's clients that
you think I really want to work with I
really want to work through it I can
have a bit worse for you there's been a
bit of trouble they've been a bit of a
nightmare and he's like why are you
wasting your time there's a few times
that that's happened I think yeah we end
up dropping some certain clients over it
which has then helped us so much in the
long run but I wouldn't have dropped
them because they're a big name client
and it's all right but it sounds good
when I say we work with and we can say
it
um but yeah there's been a few difficult
things like that it's sentimental as
well isn't it you might like liked it
when you were younger or you've known
about them since you were you were
little and then you work for them now
and it's like a bit of an ego thing oh
we work with so yeah that's do you think
people underestimate running around like
how difficult it could be running their
own recruitment business
yes yes and no depends what you want to
do with it right you know some people
set up an agency and they just want to
do it themselves
um from their their house and just them
and from that and I guess that might not
be a search but if you want to scale it
past a certain point then there's a lot
of challenges like people you don't
think about how much challenges having a
team around you really can can be but
there's a lot of every single person's
got their own challenges and stuff for
that and as the leader you have to take
them on and help them with that
personally and at work
um so yeah there's a lot of challenges
that people don't think of and
underestimate massively but it's not
something I've said but it should put
anyone off it should put anyone off
wanting to set up
um because learning and having those
challenges come up all the time develop
yourself you learn how to handle them
you learn how to handle them quickly as
well so the next time it comes up it's
stuff that you can just deal with really
quickly and move on with then how has it
evolved in terms of you thinking
like started with obviously being on
your dining room table Excel
spreadsheets all that to like now you're
working with a coach business coach or
everyone call Dave you've got nine
people in the business that's nine
people's lives that you're supporting
with the business that you're You're
Building like how has in terms of how
you're thinking about the future the
business evolved like has that become
more and more clear or have you have you
struggled with like oh let's just worry
about this year I don't know how have
you found that I'm always planning the
next thing okay I think I'm always we're
always looking at sort of five years
something I've done a lot with Dave
um but then we we feel that in with the
team as well
um which I think really motivates them
because they see the more senior
positions opening up and okay there
could be ahead of reading an era
director or on this role coming up and
okay well how do I get you there and we
sit with them and say okay if you wanted
to get to this position you know you
need to be doing this this and this
which really helps motivate them so
we're always looking into the future
um for that reason so is it is this a
business that you do want to yeah yeah
um we've got an idea of where we want to
go Manchester is definitely the next
next Manchester is so much nicer as well
I was walking around today not one
person smiled everyone said oh yeah yeah
Manchester everyone's like chatting too
yeah this is really nice but um London
you don't get that red and you don't get
it either but it's um yeah definitely we
I never want to have an office with 100
people in in one office I don't like I
wouldn't want I wouldn't want to work in
that environment so I wouldn't want to
put my team through it as well but yeah
20 30 people we think per office but
having multiple offices focusing on
local markets because like I don't know
about you but like sometimes when like
in the early stages all you can see Dart
in front of you are just like the
challenges that yeah I mean so it can be
quite hard sometimes to take a step back
and get out the weeds so that has has
that do you think that's massively
helped you just have more clarity on
decision making and making the right
decision if you know like right okay the
sort of three to five of your goal here
is going to be 25 people in Reading 25
people in Manchester because I'm
assuming you didn't always have no that
wasn't that I think that came from
working with David yeah of him saying
well what's the bigger picture because
I'd only use a plan what's the next
three months four months and having that
song that actually makes you take a step
back is massive I never used to do it I
never used to it and as soon as I've
done it the results the Billings and
motivation the office morale everything
has just gone up and up and up and then
everyone's really brought into this
bigger picture that even the first
interviews we'll go through and what A
Five-Year Plan that's like we'll just go
through it with them and then that at
that point everyone's like okay I want
to be involved in this it's crazy yeah
like a lot of people can fall into trap
thinking oh I need to worry about that
when we're bigger or at this stage but
it has such an impact even on like yeah
when you're hiring people and saying
this what you could be a part of how
large we constantly in here then how has
Harry got better at managing like all of
it seems like you've yeah been willing
to invest in yourself get help you
obviously been willing to
learn as much as you can improve along
the way with people management whatever
how have you got better at managing like
yeah all of this going on than your
personal life to make sure you're not
yeah
30kg yeah maybe like how how have you
found that it's it's a struggle it's a
struggle all the time it's not it's not
like a magic answer but certified we
spoke about before that's always been an
interesting one getting up earlier going
to bed later that kind of that kind of
stuff
um but learning to switch off as well um
for my personal stuff so it gets past
Friday at certain times I don't have my
emails come through my personal phone
but I only got my work phone with me
today
um I started leaving it behind places
she's got two different phones yeah we
didn't at the start we did a lot of
stuff with red and uni
um like the students with temp staff
like you get calls at 3am from like
people put in Sickies and stuff like
that I like people like if you had
social medias links to your phone number
not everyone's like ad in your Snapchat
and Instagram and stuff like that back
in like 2019 and I was like well I can't
be doing this so this isn't good so yeah
we switched that so having that actual
separation okay well I'm gonna go away
or whatever and leave my phone I have my
emails on my phone obviously but the
notifications don't come through
um it's the managing the work-life
balance is is the thing and everyone
speaks about right now isn't it about
does everyone actually have one
um so past a certain time I won't do it
I won't try to work phone past eight
o'clock
um it's those rules that I've built into
my life that then I've managed to be
that I can actually enjoy both both
sides of it so that they've been some of
the habits that you've worked on yeah
building massively it's stuff like when
I'm on a holiday so I'm trying not to
check my emails I do it all the time but
I do that once I let myself check in the
morning and I'll look and then the next
day so so obviously you're just sharing
about getting better at Wildlife balance
yeah trying to sort of get better yeah
having habits that help you switch off
these types of things
yeah interested to hear how you found I
know obviously when we last boat I don't
know it might have been before you went
away or whatever like how have you found
stepping away from the business knowing
you've got your office full of young
young people there cracking on without
you there I don't know how have you
found that uh it's at the start it was
challenging now I've got a lot of trust
in my team
um there's so much for us there and I
know there's certain people that if
people were slacking what are you doing
like come on let's let's get on with
this
um so a lot of trust there but if I go
away I'll get loads of random FaceTime
calls not about work or anything like
that when I was in Greece I thought
maybe I might be just like we were
probably just relaxing in a Dream from
like nine a.m and stuff like that and
I'd get a call then oh yeah this sick
thing happened I'll be sat there just
like absolutely smash but um it was
quite an interesting time I went to
screenshots they got taken whilst I was
away as well they FaceTime me and I'm
like just yeah but um I I trust them a
lot there's a lot of trust that I give
them like um quite a lot of autonomy
around even their day-to-day stuff we
don't have um start time and finish
times
so they have their core hours so someone
gets at 9 30 and then normally leave at
six and everyone just makes up these
these hours and stuff that's where we
put a lot of trust in them it's a lot
that's given back to us so then I'm
never like worrying like oh what's
happening I wonder
okay someone booking an interviews
because at the end of the day if they're
not booking an interviews they're not
making commission so I've learned that
part I used to be like calling like four
or five times a day but now man I trust
these people that are my business in
safe hands because
at the end of the day they want it to be
part of their business as well they want
to be growing with it as well and
everything like that and like shares and
stuff like that so I trust them
to do it so it's been a hard challenge
to do that but again I think that
anchors back down to like the thing
you've been doing with Dave around like
what the future looks like what they're
part of because if you do the work on
that and you do a good job of
communicating it then they're the sorts
of things that these people should be
thinking about are leaning into as to
like why they want to why they need to
do it I get drunk text off Jack all the
time in particular saying I hate him
till I die and stuff like that it cracks
me up and I'm like I'm all right all
right wake up well like I'm not drinking
it's fair you don't drink alone either
but like yeah we'd go a nice out I'd
hear him like shouting it from the other
side of the bar and stuff like that and
it's like I can't not like I'm away I'm
out like there's so much trust there and
stuff obviously he's not being serious
but it might be I don't know but has
that become one of the best parts then
yeah
the people in the culture we've built um
it's like it's written on our walls um
culture comes first
um the new people that started in the
academy they've really bought into it as
well
um and they've settled in so quickly
um like I walked in the other day and
one of them was like oh you're right and
said a rude word about me and I'm like I
think about you guys were like and it's
just yeah it's funny but at school I
went to was a Quaker School which is
like a really weird thing but everyone's
equal so you don't get you know
hierarchy and stuff like that and we've
kind of put that into the business so
everyone kind of feels on the same the
same level although there's certain
times obviously no it's not on
everything but the culture is so good at
the moment and everything like that
which is why we're so so fast about who
we bring in and that's what's led to the
trust and me to be able to step away and
you know going a night out of take a day
off and go up to see my mates in
Manchester I hope I'm not have to
actually worry about what's what's
happening now so so to wrap up then I
guess what we could just hear your your
thoughts on would be like yeah if I'm
I'm listening to this I'm 20 years old
yeah I found myself uh having some
recruitment experience and I'm like you
know what I I really fancy this
entrepreneurial journey I don't want to
work for someone else anymore
what what what advice would you give
them or what would you say to them
because that was you first thing I'd say
is like what you got to lose because
remember someone said that to me don't
ask me hope because I have no idea I
should remember that but then I was like
what have you got to lose
let's say let's say you do it for six
months and doesn't work out what are
people gonna think oh they're gonna
think he's failed no they're going to
think it's a 20 20 year old trying is
like fair play a lot of respect I would
never look at someone's Journey if they
failed a set of business and like laugh
about it you'd think fair play like
there's a lot of respect there's a lot
of guts there a lot of courage and
everything like that
um like if you didn't try it would you
regret it as well so if you end up
saying no you know I'm gonna work go
work for another agency in six months
time or a year or two years you'll say
you're a top Biller that could have been
for your business so I always think
about that and just just go for it
you've got nothing to lose
um well that's actually there is when
you actually look in a bit more detail
right but there's nothing to lose in
what other people think because it
doesn't matter what they think because
what happens if it goes really well yeah
I think the fair play to you because I
think clearly you've been on a
you run obviously the business is
growing but then you've obviously
clearly been on your own personal yeah
Journey as well starting from which
you've done it in table to then like
clearly building a culture that you're
proud of having people on the journey
working with people like Dave to help
you understand right okay yeah how can I
think about this business in three five
years time rather than just three months
ahead like clearly being willing to like
you said have guts do things differently
and yeah I think just nothing but
respect really and kudos to that so
thanks to look on the pub mate I enjoyed
it thank you so much for listening to
the episode I hope you enjoyed it and
got value from the conversation if you
did enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode